in discussions of Islamic terror very
often this idea comes up of who are the
real Muslims is anyone who says they're
a must them a real Muslim is anyone who
says they are inspired by their
interpretation of the Quran for example
a Muslim or can we write off anyone who
commits an atrocity under the name of
Islam as being quote not really Muslim
this is a conversation that I actually
had with mark Sandlin back in 2013 what
is real Christianity and it is so
relevant now in the context of these
discussions of well are they real
Muslims or not is the candidate a true
Christian or not so we're going to go
back to my great great conversation with
Mark Sandlin from October of 2013
let's take a look I'm joined today by
former Navy chaplain Gordon
Klingenschmitt check out his website
pray in jesus name.org also joined by
reverend mark Sandlin mark is a
Presbyterian minister co-founder of the
Christian Left also blogs for the
Huffington Post and a number of other
publications gentlemen it's really great
to have both of you here today you know
you may not know this but my audience
certainly does I am NOT an expert in
Christianity I was born into a Jewish
family and raised relatively secular but
it's impossible to ignore that
Christianity is very involved in the
politics of the United States so it's a
topic that we often discuss so I want to
go first to the chaplain chaplain you
know you and I have talked about a
variety of issues we've talked about
gays and gay marriage abortion the
teaching of evolution Obamacare
single-payer health care poverty what do
you think right now should be the most
important and and paramount issues to
American Christians in the political
system well thank you David for having
me on your show once again and god bless
you and god bless your listeners in
Jesus name as a former Navy chaplain I
believe in the Constitution of the
United States I'm an air
Academy graduate I defend the First
Amendment
among all the other constitutional
amendments and religious freedom is a
critical issue that the church and my
constituents are very concerned about so
now sadly under the Obama administration
I feel like and many of my friends feel
like Christian values are under attack
and being legislated out of existence by
the Liberals in the Obama administration
who want to for example redefine
traditional marriage instead of as Jesus
to find it between one man and one woman
they want to pass the defense you know
strike down the Defense of Marriage Act
enact the end bill Employment
non-discrimination Act and we've seen
this trend going on for many years this
is not new to anyone in your audience
but you asked me what are some of the
critical issues well I mean I think
that's that's good in the interest of
getting reverend mark in because that
right there was chock-full of stuff that
I'm sure he wants to address so reverend
mark just even on the basis do you agree
with that with with chaplain clinging to
its assessment that jesus made it clear
what a marriage should be or do you do
you disagree there
disagree with anyone who follows us on
the christian lap notice that we believe
that biblically there's actually all
kinds of representations of what blessed
relationships look like in god
particularly when when that kind of
language is used to kind of deny rights
to folks who are who are in same-sex
relationships so I think it's pretty
clear that Jesus was much more
interested in love and bringing people
together and in relationships where
people trust each other and care for
each other and promote the greater good
through it so you don't believe that V
do you think let's let's to address the
chaplains other assertion there do you
think there has been a significant
change in terms of religious freedom
under President Obama religious freedom
I would think actually has been opened
up we've seen more and more acceptance
of a greater variety of religions I have
clawed chaps for is defending the rights
of other religions on the naval ships to
practice their religion
and I think that's what we ought to be
doing in the US rather than trying to
legislate our particular beliefs we need
to be trying to look for higher moral
grounds and open up the platform so that
more and more religions are respected
and accepted and aren't having other
people's perspectives forced on them
chaplain feel free to jump in well thank
you as a conservative traditional
Christian you know some people may say
that I'm on the Christian Right My
partner here Reverend mark is on the
Christian left or so he describes
himself I want to suggest that the
definition of Christian we need to be
very careful about this should be
somebody who follows Jesus Christ
somebody who agrees with Jesus and
somebody who believes the Bible I think
a lot of people out there on the
so-called left are trying to call
themselves Christian but at the same
time they don't believe in Jesus Christ
they don't let him rule their heart and
mind and they don't believe the Bible
Jesus Christ defined marriage between
one man and one woman and people who
disagree with that should not call
themselves Christians or followers of
Jesus and David I think this is what
this type of conversation always ends up
unfortunately
unraveling to's who gets to call
themselves Christian and who who doesn't
and who owns the right interpretation of
what Jesus said and what Jesus didn't
say and I think right there at the end
you did a very important hermeneutical
moving and pointing to the fact that
Jesus was using the Old Testament his
Jewish holy scripture to understand
things because I think we have to look
at all of it and so I think it's a
little dogmatic and a little limiting
when we we pick one verse we quote it
and say that it represents a full
understanding of who were supposed to be
or what Jesus taught because Jesus grew
up with all these other scriptures as
well and he frequently referred to them
and they informed who he was so I don't
particularly get into having a debate of
who's Christian and who's not I think
that's a little presumptive to propose
another topic through which we can kind
of explore the differences in our views
here the chaplain brought up the issue
of marriage equality I want to talk a
little bit about health care there has
been a significant conservative
Christian movement against the
Affordable
a kind of colloquially known as
Obamacare and further there's also been
sentiment that single-payer health care
or health care for all would somehow not
be in line with Christianity for some
reason
I'll go first now to reverend mark
reverend mark is your sense that the the
jesus view would be everyone should be
provided with some basic level of health
care or is that not the the proper
interpretation about jesus anytime
anyone asks for health care jesus gave
it to do so just from practice i would
say that something was important to
jesus now the argument is usually that
yeah well jesus didn't force the
government to do it well what jesus was
really doing was making sure that those
in need had it so I would say if we're
capable of making sure that folks who
need health care had it without the
government's intervention and that's
great the reality is we haven't chaplain
you've been very outspoken against
Obamacare how do you what do you think
of Reverend Mark's comments well I agree
with his sentiment that God should be
the healer we should look to God for
healing and not to the government I
think sadly the Socialists left has now
been trying to replace private charities
and Christian hospitals or regulate them
into obscurity or even to takeover with
government power some of the things that
Christians have been doing for a
thousand years I believe in free market
enterprise I believe in private charity
sadly since President Obama has been
elected four point nine million
working-class Americans have lost their
health care insurance between ages 25
and 64 and that hurts everybody's
ability to have health care so socialism
is not a way to give more health care as
socialism actually takes health care
away from people in its anti-christian
when I pray for the sick by the way I
was in India last year I preached 34
times in 35 days and in 4 cities we
prayed for the sick and by the power of
God people were healed and we saw a
miracle so I think God should be the
healer and we should not look to
government as if it is a God mark I
think there's probably a lot you would
want to say
that but because the because we have
limited time and Chaplin has kind of
opened the door to discussing something
else
the Chaplin has talked about faith
healing and we've had cases where people
parents have actually now had to face
charges for providing only faith healing
and no traditional medical treatments to
their kids
the chaplain on my program has also
talked about exorcisms and that he
personally with about a fifty percent
success rate has been able to exercise
the homosexuality out of people is that
in line with your understanding of
Christian teachings or does that sound
like something that is outside of
Christianity I think there's two
different questions going on there one
is healing and one is exercising and
I'll say right up front I have certainly
never been privileged to be in the
presence of any of that actually
happening and in a way that I could
verify that that was what occurred so
from a purely experiential point of view
it's difficult for me to completely
understand although we have biblical
text of healings of course I've never
seen it and I've never seen it
particularly verified for those who
would like to replace health care with
biblical healing or praying for someone
to heal I would challenge them to drop
their own health care and not going to a
hospital and just pray by suspect
long-run we're gonna decide not to do
that and there's yeah the exorcisms
because like I said the chaplain says he
has this 50% success rate that a lesbian
once wept and then was no longer
interested in other women and he has a
lot of these stories which to some
people seem hard to believe of why a
person has the traction the same someone
of the same sex are you do you believe
that it is a possession of the devil or
do you believe that as science is slowly
beginning to show us some signs up that
there's also parts of that that has to
do with how we're wired in our DNA and
our structure and who we are and so and
some about our environment and the
people that we find ourselves attracted
to so chaplain feel free to address that
I know this is an important topic to you
I don't want to mischaracterize my
position I think Reverend Mark suggested
that I'm against healthcare because I
believe God is the hue
that's not what I said at all I'm in
favor of health care I'm a member of the
Knights Hospitaller
which is the organization the Knights of
Malta that founded the first hospitals
which they just unearthed in Jerusalem
over a thousand years ago with regard to
exorcism here's here's what Jesus taught
right and you read this Gospels Matthew
Mark Luke and John
especially in Matthew 10 where Jesus
commanded his disciples and I try to be
one of his disciples to heal the sick
cleanse the lepers cast out demons raise
the dead and that doesn't mean we have
the power to do that but we should try
and we should certainly pray that God
will give us that power to heal people
who are ruled by demons not everybody's
ruled by a demon there's not a demon
behind every bush but there is perhaps
an evil influence but behind every human
sin and when you can't define sano there
is no such thing as sin then of course
you don't believe in the devil but if
you believe the Bible if you believe
what Jesus says there is right and wrong
the devil is influencing people to sin
and the Spirit of God is influencing
people to choose holiness then ever in
every human moral decision you have an
opportunity to agree with God or to
disagree with God to agree with the
devil or disagree with the devil and
those are just natural choices that
people make in the context of human
morality every day that's why it's
sexual immorality because it is defined
as wrong outside of the context of
traditional marriage between one man and
one woman sexual morality is a
temptation it's a sin and therefore we
consent to allow the devil to rule that
part of our life and we could renounce
that we can walk away from that it's not
part of your DNA and David we've talked
about punnett squares and Mendelian
genetics and how homosexuality can't not
be inherited because when a man mates
with another man they don't have kids
and so the only way they have is to
recruit the children of heterosexual
couples into that movement in therefore
it's not genetic it's not biological it
is a moral choice and therefore it can
be repented of it you can invite God to
rule that part of your heart reverend
mark is this discussion of
of homosexuality as as a chosen sin and
everything else that the chaplain is
talking about is to you is is this a
productive area for Christianity to
focus within the nomination have this
discussion is that frankly even if you
think that the English interpretation of
the Bible is literally a correct
translation in the places that it
addresses homosexual relationships which
is only seven in general the Bible is
disinterested in this subject and we put
probably more than 50% of our time it
would seem into dealing with this issue
I think it's a distraction from what we
should be doing which is seeking justice
and equality trying to encourage people
to work towards peace and getting along
with their neighbors no matter what they
look like
alright well gentlemen I think we've
said it all we've been speaking to
former Navy chaplain Gordon
Klingenschmitt check out his website
pray in jesus name.org also reverend
mark Sandlin who's a presbyterian
minister he's the co-founder of the
christian left and blogs on huffington
post and elsewhere on the internet
thanks to both of you for joining me
today
thank you David a thank you mark god
bless you in Jesus David good to see it